MARKUS KLUTE: Hello, everybody.
So this set of slides is on the
organization of this course.
It's part of the syllabus.
I'll explain how the
course is structured,
how you participate,
how you'll be graded,
and I'll give you
some details and where
to find proper pointers.
To get started,
this class will be
taught in an inverted classroom
or flipped classroom setting,
and it's going to be
online-only so we will not
have in-person
opportunities to discuss.
There's a second video
where I'll just briefly talk
about the strategy of
the inverted classroom
and the benefits.
What you are typically
used for as lectures
is organized solely
in short videos
where I discuss
concepts or methods.
The videos also include
a few short questions
for your own
self-evaluation, and we'll
pick up those questions and
later in recitation session.
So when you meet
Tuesdays and Thursdays
we'll have time to
answer your questions.
We'll have time to go
through those [INAUDIBLE]
and hopefully have
a good discussion.
The recitations are also used
for another concept, which
I'll explain on a
later slide, which
is your presentation
of a specific paper.
This is part of
your homework set
is to find a paper to discuss
with me whether or not
it fits into this
class schedule,
and together with a partner,
have a short discussion of it.
So we'll use these Tuesday
and Thursday sessions
for this purpose.
And in addition, there's going
to be an office hour on Friday.
It's one hour where I'm just
going to be connected to a Zoom
meeting.
You can log in at
any time and we'll
discuss whatever you
want to talk about.
For that let's contribute
to the Doodle poll, which
I posed during the
first [INAUDIBLE] time
of the first class,
and then we'll
find the best possible time
for everybody involved.
The course evaluation or your
evaluation in this course
will be made up 50%
out of homework.
So it's going to be six
PSets are going to be posted.
One will be forgiven so I'll
basically count five PSets,
and each will allow you
to accumulate 8 points.
The paper presentation
I was talking about
will have 20 points.
We're talking about a 20-minute
presentation of a paper.
It's really a summary of
a paper of your choice
together with 10
minutes of Q&A. Again,
this is being done
in two groups so you
have to split up the aspect
of presenting-- preparing
and presenting,
and then also when
it comes to the response
and the questions.
And then there's going to
be two short oral exams.
This is 20 minutes,
so the actual exam
is only going to be 15 minutes,
with the teaching staff,
so this is Justin
and myself where
we ask you a couple
of questions and just
make sure that you are on top
of the content we discussed
in the weeks prior.
So there is two.
The first one deals with the
particle physics content,
and the second one with
the nuclear physics
and experimental method as well.
The grading scheme
will not be worse
than what I've given you here.
The great divide-- the great
divide or the grade divide--
at 85% between A and
B, 70% between B and C,
60% between C and
D, and below 50%
earns you an F. I
don't think anybody
can get into this environment
as long as they participate.